son los rostros de las víctimas del
tiroteo en el distrito diez de París
eminecara líder del movimiento de
mujeres kurdas en Francia según el
portavoz del Consejo democrático culta
en el país europeo cara había solicitado
asilo político en esa nación un pedido
rechazado por las autoridades otra de
las víctimas fue un reconocido cantante
kurdo mir perware identificado como
refugiado político había sido procesado
en Turquía por su manera de crear la
tercera víctima fue Abdul raman kisil un
ciudadano kurdo que frecuentaba el sitio
de los hechos Mientras tanto este sábado
la comunidad kurda salió a la calle para
manifestarse en contra del ataque y a
pedir más acciones del gobierno francés
para protegerlos
están tratando de hacernos creer que
esto es un asesinato racista que estos
asesinatos son cometidos por un hombre
mentalmente inestable aceptar esta tesis
está fuera de la discusión
el simple hecho de atacar el centro
democrático kurdo es un acto político un
asesinato político
también continuaron los enfrentamientos
con las autoridades del orden
el tirador un hombre de 69 años confesó
el corte racista de sus actos sobre el
pesan cargos de asesinato violencia
agravada y homicidio doloso